hi reg be it or good morning here's our
question
give me the team that should be nervous
here of the favorites in the first round
Wow I think you can make a case for all
of them probably except the game I'm
doing tonight in Minnesota Houston I
think James Hart and Chris Paul you'll
probably see their best game tonight not
to say that they're gonna win it but you
know what we saw at games one and two it
was almost like a runaway and I give all
the credit to Thibodeau and Minnesota
and Game three but if I had to make a
case for the higher seeds I really
believe that Indiana Cleveland series is
going seven okay and I do believe right
now Ricky Rubio and the rookie Donovan
Mitchell
they've outplayed Russell Westbrook and
Paul George and man although you can
make a case for all of them except for
State yeah Golden State is gonna say
they're gonna wrap that yeah yeah
Toronto against Washington and how about
this we've got teams in in these series
that really don't like one another you
know we we've seen the barking at one
another flagrant fouls the technicals
the unsportsmanlike contact the hostile
acts I think Washington now has gotten
their footing but can their game travel
I don't think they can win a game north
of the border in Toronto yeah but now
you've extended the series though and
anything is possible and injuries come
into play now a little tweaked ankle
here we saw that two ankle injuries even
though Durant came back and played well
last night had 34 points you gotta take
those factors into account what about
the Lance Stephenson you know this is
kind of a throwback to the 90s where you
you have that guy who just is you know
he's the pebble in your in your shoe
he's been very antagonistic
and I last week I mention that you know
the Pacers could not care less playing
against LeBron James they weren't going
to be in awe and there's history there
obviously between these two franchises
when LeBron was with the Miami Heat
so Lance has been down this road before
and look Cleveland can easily be up 3-1
I mean I think they blew Game three when
they were up 17 in Indiana walked him
down the found a warrior to win that
ballgame and in my opinion Indiana
should have won last night I think it
has the writing's on the wall but the
reason why I think this game is going
seven Ron James is playing a lot of
minutes for a guy that's been in the
league 15 years I mean these
back-to-back games where he's played the
whole second half and unless someone
come steps up it can play consistently
for the Cavs because there's been
different players at different times
they're just gonna where LeBron James
down that's why I believe this series is
going seven I think both teams
I think leave them at home and they will
win Game five and when it comes back to
Indiana they'll win at home and then
it's a free-for-all for Game seven back
in in Cleveland why is it that Cleveland
has no consistency well you've got guys
that haven't really been in the playoffs
or had success in the playoffs that
you're counting on Clarkson Nance hood
they've played well in spots but these
are guys that you have to count
especially young legs you've got to you
have to account for these young players
and this is their first time in the fire
Korver has made big shots for them Kevin
Love has been she's been good but he
hasn't been great and these are guys gr
Smith I mean you don't know what you're
gonna get
you don't although I give him credit
that I would just say look your job is
to be a pass to Victor Oladipo that's it
don't try to do anything other than that
occasionally hit a three if you can but
just play defense because if you can
kind of you can't stop him you hope to
contain him and if you do that then you
can move on in the series but if not
play dray he did not play greats in
games three and four at home he made
shots he
with he was okay but he wasn't great
we're talking to Reggie Miller Reggie's
got tonight's game for between the
Rockets and the Timberwolves if
Cleveland doesn't advance what is that
it does not Cleveland doesn't so what's
that mean long term do you think you
know that we know the immediacy of that
you're not gonna have Cleveland for the
NBA Finals but what do you think it
means the next you know one two three
four years for the NBA well I think
serious question James is going to say
yes but are you more likely to stay or
less likely to stay reg I mean you're
looking at that roster
I wouldn't I'd go wait whose can anybody
step up here tonight not that he didn't
help build this roster but I think he's
looking around going man it's a mess
well it depends on how they go out as
well I think if they would have gone
down 3-1 and lost in five certainly the
Bron James was gone
if this goes seven games main loses in
seven games I think he'll take a harder
look at it but it still it's gonna be
hard to fathom LeBron James going out in
the first round something he's never
done in his career
well script that let's say that he
doesn't get to the finals like what's
best for the league if flah Bron doesn't
make it to the fun what if Philadelphia
says hey LeBron hey we we don't need you
okay we're good we got a point forward
here I think you've got storylines with
Philly obviously with him bead he's a
he's great in front of Mike he's got
game to back it up Ben Simmons I mean a
rookie out here a redshirt rookie out
here getting triple doubles so you've
got story lines behind Philadelphia but
I mean this going into Miami and winning
two road games you're seeing a young
team grew up in front of our eyes yeah
they're funny I mean that's a hostile
environment and you talk about two teams
not liking one another I mean come on
why is it is the very definition why
don't we get that comparison with Ben
Simmons with Magic Johnson I know it
sounds blasphemous but we're always
trying to
the next Michael I think we have the
next magic or at least as close as
possible I don't see him as LeBron I see
him more as as magic it but we don't we
don't we don't go there why is that does
magic wasn't a great shooter he became a
better knockdown shooter but he did but
his rookie year though he could score a
little bit better than what Simmons does
Simmons can score first of all we don't
know what hand Ben Simmons is well you
forget just how great magic was that
rookie season but you know Ben Ben
Simmons has lived up to the hype and
that's hard to do
given the hype that we we keep on these
kids and it kind of you know harkens
back to Magic Johnson's rookie year when
Kareem went down in the finals vs.
philadelphia and who had to run points
in ER on their way to the title it's
kind of what Simmons has done I know
that MB displayed the last couple games
but if you look over the last month
while them bead was out it was all Ben
Simmons yeah and beads fun man yeah he's
character character he really is to back
it up which I love and how about this
pleading to play a game and to start
your playoff series on the road it
wasn't like he was pleading to come back
and friends I thought the home faithful
no put me in a hostile environment and
let me go after them that's what I loved
about him he does he he does not care
where he's at what do you think of the
Jazz uniforms I like them I don't people
a lot of people are throw backs and they
like the traditionals I like the color
spots I do kind of like you'd be a
Phoenix Suns Jersey more than Utah I
mean I guess they're taken advantage of
like the National Monument or the
national parks there and the sort of red
rocks and all that stuff I guess
now do we consider that an upset if Utah
when's this series four no five can go
right that's the other thing four or
five can go either way
yeah just like just like Cleveland
Indiana it's not a huge upset well okay
what are you what happens to Oklahoma
City if they bow out first round oh man
we got huge decisions if LeBron James
loses in the first round yes Cleveland
and Paul George yeah for OKC yeah I just
can't see I think both was what it will
end up staying with their respective
organizations but huge huge decisions to
be made down the road yeah I don't know
III if LA Braun bounced out early
there's no way he's gonna look at that
roster and go yep this is where I want
to be the next four years just no way
reg well we talked about certain
scenarios where LeBron can end up
weakest I could see him in Houston that
would be scary but I mean there's only
one ball to go along with Chris Paul and
James Harden I just don't see him with
the Lakers unless there's been
conversations behind closed doors with
other players yeah that hey no matter
what we're going to the Lakers and in
terms of Paul George yeah I just don't I
don't see him with the Lakers I don't in
a crowded Western Conference don't
forget you still have Houston and you'll
have Golden State I just don't see
LeBron being out there it's an easier
path unless he sees Philadelphia as the
up-and-coming team which I think a lot
of people do as well as Boston or
Boston's playing you know everyone's up
to you know the sky was falling in
Milwaukee's the way they got blown out
in games one and two now I think the
advantage you have to say is Milwaukee
in that series now right I have no idea
like Milwaukee's an enigma to me I just
it is hard you're right but that's what
the beauty of the playoffs is all about
yeah but help me everyone thought
everyone thought Minnesota was dead in
the water in in Game three great crowd
great atmosphere better energy Derrick
Rose look like the MVP from a Chicago
Derrick Rose must avenge jeff Teague I
mean there was a karl-anthony towns
sighting better energy so dude can they
put back-to-back games together tonight
and when here even it up and go back to
Houston can their game travel if they
could even up this series to to put
pressure back on Houston
you said travel are you gonna call out
James Harden at all tonight if he
travels reg when he travels when he
travels if Randy travels I may say
something if they don't call it but can
you remember anybody who traveled like
that much the consistency that James
Harden is well I could look myself in
the mirror but they never called it they
can't call every travel wait you travel
you got you were a guy who travel I
thought you were just no I had great
footwork and of course you did I had
look I went to UCLA fundamentals baby
John Wooden pyramid of success Reggie
just admitted to traveling he's the
first NBA player in history hey
occasionally traveled you flopped I know
that are you want to admit that come on
reg let it all out you want to just
expunge your sins here so you traveled
you flopped anything else what else do
you want to admit to reg come on I'm
your doctor Phil here okay MJ that kind
of was a push off a little bit right
okay so Michael pushed off on Russell
yes it should have been called and I
pushed off on it ah MJ Oh on that shot
oh okay what's the wait a minute you're
not saying Jordan pushed off on on Brian
Russell okay
yeah and that's in Utah and they never
call bad reg correct
so that's Michael Jordan well why an
official swallow their whistle because
it's games
no because it's mine that's because I'm
Michael but they tend to let the team's
figure it out wait a minute
if that was Steve Kerr who
that they wouldn't let Steve Kerr get
away with it I would pay money to see
Steve Kerr 101 and push off like that I
don't think Steve Kerr ever took more
than like you know two consecutive
dribbles did he I'd be like he just
would stand there catch shoot so yeah
you're right that that never would have
happened all right are you calling for
the well you can't predict tonight right
no okay there's a no call for a great
game in a great atmosphere
mm-hmm I mean it's been 15 years since
this franchise has been in the playoffs
that if game three was any indication it
is going to be loud and raunchy and I
cannot wait run love to see them keeps
yes very raunchy raunchy all right well
I hope like karl-anthony towns
comes out and starts firing away here
gets better I think tonight will be a
huge game for karl-anthony towns he
played just okay I mean he had better
numbers in Game three yeah I think
tonight karl-anthony towns goes crazy
and I think James Harden will have one
of those 40 point games today
double double triple on the verge of a
triple-double I think James Harden goes
crazy tonight yeah does he acknowledge
you when you you see him yeah Mike would
would you walk by and harden goes what's
he say I'll give them the fake bro-hug
have a good game and keep it moving
that's it yeah everyone yeah but I
didn't know if like you know like NBA
royalty like your whole-- Famer like he
did so what's up reg man I love ya I'm
cool with everyone okay have no beef no
I might talk a little on the air about
you keeping it on it all right well
we'll see if reg calls how James Harden
for traveling tonight not for me this is
for you this is this is for truth and
justice and the American Way
no you just said backstab Wow no the
step back yeah I love James Hart but
it's the bunny hop after this debt back
yeah come on that that's a travel why
don't you break it
down so the audience can see and then
you can kind of be circling the feet
there I will all right reg tonight with
Kevin Harlan the award-winning Kevin
Harlan that's at 8:00 Eastern on TNT the
Rockets in the Timberwolves reg these
are you are truly the best love you all
day I see you buddy that's Reggie
Aloysius Miller jr. the third for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]